[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an meiner Seite ist Norbert
Lehmann für den Sport
in einem ihrer wichtigsten sozialen
Vorhaben ist die Regierung einen Schritt
weiter
Einigung nach langem Streit die
Koalition will mit der
Kindergrundsicherung die Auszahlung
staatlicher Leistungen vereinfachen
ungewöhnliche Klage vor Europäischen
Gerichtshof Kinder und Jugendliche aus
Portugal fordern strengere Klimaziele
von Deutschland und 31 weiteren Staaten
eine Hommage zu lorius
für komische Kunst zeigt mehr als 700
Exponate
mehr Kinder aus der Armut holen das ist
das Ziel der Bundesregierung oft wissen
Familien gar nicht welche Leistungen
Ihnen zustehen und wie Sie sie
beantragen sollen genau das soll die
Kindergrundsicherung ändern nach langem
Streit hat der Gesetzentwurf heute eine
weitere Hürde genommen das Kabinett hat
sein Okay gegeben
aus zwei Komponenten soll die
Kindergrundsicherung bestehen einem
garantierten Betrag der das bisherige
Kindergeld ersetzt und einem
Zusatzbetrag der mögliche andere
Leistungen bündelt unter anderem den
Kinderzuschlag kommen soll die grüne die
Grundsicherung schrittweise ab 2025 zur
Größenordnung ursprünglich waren fürs
erste Jahr zusätzliche 12 Milliarden
Euro angedacht zugesagt sind jetzt nur
noch 2,4 viel zu wenig meinen Kritiker
Britta Spiekermann
ein Sicherheitsnetz für alle Kinder und
Familien soll die Kindergrundsicherung
sein so verspricht es die
Bundesfamilienministerin die
Kindergrundsicherung ist der Einstieg in
eine wirksame und grundlegende
Bekämpfung der strukturellen Kinderarmut
in Deutschland
wir fassen alle relevanten Leistungen
für Kinder zu einer Leistung zusammen
monatelang hatten Lisa Pause und der
Bundesfinanzminister über die Kosten
gestritten Lindner auf der Bremse Pause
musste nachgeben fast 3 Millionen Kinder
und Jugendliche leben von staatlichen
Leistungen viele obwohl ihre Eltern
arbeiten Familien sollen jetzt aktiv vom
Staat auf Ihre Ansprüche hingewiesen
werden der Staat also in der Bringschuld
dass die neue Kindergrundsicherung ein
Weg aus der Armut ist daran haben
Sozialverbände erhebliche Zweifel
dafür hätte man Geld in die Hand nehmen
müssen dadurch dafür hätte man die
Leistungen wirklich deutlich verbessern
müssen das ist nicht passiert man hat es
bei einer reinen Verwaltungsreform im
Prinzip belassen finanzielle Vorteile
könnte es für Alleinerziehende geben
Nachteile hingegen für Kinder von
Asylbewerbern denen 20 Euro pro Monat
gestrichen werden sollen von der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit der
ausführenden Behörde Bedenken ob der
Starttermin 1 Januar 2025 überhaupt
realistisch ist 2000 neue Stellen sollen
geschaffen werden die CDU sieht jetzt
nur noch mehr Probleme
für uns ist dieser Entwurf so wie wir
ihn jetzt vorliegen haben nach wie vor
ein großes Bürokratiemonster ein Abbau
sehen wir nicht jetzt muss der
Gesetzentwurf noch durch Parlament und
Bundesrat die Zustimmung unionsgeführter
Länder ist mehr als fraglich
die große
asylrechtsreform der EU liegt derzeit
auf Eis auch wegen einer deutschen
lokale für die die Grünen verantwortlich
sind heute nun einen Tag bevor die
Innenminister in Brüssel beraten hat der
Kanzler sich geäußert Berlin werde in
Brüssel nichts aufhalten
in Berlin was ist das ein Machtwort das
Kanzlers um die Grünen auf Linie zu
bringen
nein ein Machtwort soll es im Kabinett
nicht gegeben haben das haben wir jetzt
mehrere Sitzungsteilnehmer bestätigt da
ist man sich einig danach aber laufen
die Interpretationen auseinander die
einen sprechen von handlungsleitenden
Worten des Kanzlers das kommt dann schon
einer klaren Ansage wenn nicht Anweisung
sehr nah die bärburg-seite sagt es habe
lediglich einen Appell des Kanzlers
gegeben die morgige Sitzungen in Brüssel
zu nutzen um voranzukommen es geht im
Wesentlichen dabei um die sogenannte
krisenverordnung mit der Staaten bei
krisenhafter migrationslage
beispielsweise die haftähnliche
Unterbringung von Migranten verlängern
und auch die humanitären Standards
absenken können
Außenministerin hatte das wie auch viele
andere grüne bisher abgelehnt damit aber
die gesamte in Brüssel geplante Reform
des eu-asylrechts blockiert nach dem
heutigen Appell oder der Ansage des
Kanzlers könnte jetzt Innenministerin
Phaser morgen auf der europäischen
Innenminister Konferenz dann dazu
beitragen Einigkeit zu erzielen im
Auswärtigen Amt jedenfalls heißt es am
Abend jetzt wird in Brüssel endlich
richtig verhandelt
danke für diese Einschätzung aus Berlin
dankeschön tierkohl
Innenministerin Faeser hat erweiterte
Kontrollen im Grenzgebiet zu Polen und
Tschechien angekündigt geplant seinen
flexible Schwerpunktkontrollen an
wechselnden Orten entlang der
schleuserrouten die Auswirkungen auf
Pendler und die Wirtschaft im
Grenzgebiet sollten so gering wie
möglich gehalten werden
stationäre Grenzkontrollen schloss sie
für die Zukunft aber nicht aus unions-
33 Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung sind
Spuren der Teilung Deutschlands immer
noch sichtbar einige sind aber auch
verschwunden so stets im heute
vorgestellten Bericht zur deutschen
Einheit mittlerweile angeglichen die
Rentenwerte in West und Ost ebenso der
Anteil der Studienanfängerinnen und
Anfänger unterschiedlich bleibt das
verfügbare Haushaltseinkommen im Osten
haben die Menschen durchschnittlich 11
Prozent weniger besonders schwierig ist
es die Lebensbedingungen in den
ländlichen Regionen aus Deutschlands
anzugleichen Andreas kühnerst
das ist der typische Osten das Städtchen
Koren Salis unweit von Leipzig in dem
das Gasthaus Weg ist die Apotheke dicht
die Sparkasse geschlossen und jetzt
macht auch noch der Konsum der letzte
laden zu und das ist der typische Osten
Dresden die 5 Milliarden Euro Baustelle
von Infineon Magdeburg der 30 Milliarden
Euro Entwurf von Intel Erfurt die zwei
Milliarden Batterie Fabrik von kattel es
stehen zwei gegenläufige Entwicklungen
im Jahresbericht zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit zu wenig Arbeitsplätze auf dem
Land zu wenig Arbeitskräfte in den
boomenden Städten sind ganz andere
Voraussetzung als noch vor 10 Jahren und
es wird jedes Jahr über die
Herausforderung schlimmer also
herausfordern sag mal so das gerate der
Osten nicht nur Rückwanderung sondern
auch Zuwanderung braucht wie es die
Bundesregierung sagt wird gerade im
Osten besonders laut gestritten für die
Wut für das um für hoch der AFD macht
die Opposition die Regierung
mitverantwortlich wir wissen ja dass wir
ein deutliche einkommens- und
vermögensunterschied haben und ich
persönlich meine das ist eine
Hauptursache für auch den Frust mit der
ampelregierung
ostdeutscher verspricht die Ampel bei
der Besetzung von Führungspositionen zu
werden so leiten bisher nur zwei
ostdeutsche eine Universität
am Ende ist es so dass ich schon merke
dass die fehlende Präsenz von
ostdeutschen die fehlende bewusste
Präsenz auch dazu führt dass bis heute
viele solcher Themen gar nicht vorkommen
den typischen Osten gibt es nicht mehr
aber noch typische Unterschiede sie
werden noch lange bleiben
Innenministerin Väter hat einen weiteren
rechtsextremistischen Verein verboten
die
artgemeinschaft gegründet 1951 in zwölf
Bundesländern durchsuchten Einsatzkräfte
26 Wohnungen und Vereinsräume die Gruppe
ist nach Einschätzung des
Innenministeriums eine sektenartige
zutiefst rassistische und antisemitische
Organisation
der Volkswagenkonzern hat mit einer
massiven it-störung zu kämpfen die
zentrale Infrastruktur sei lahmgelegt
die Produktion stehe seit dem frühen
Nachmittag in mehreren Werken still
bestätigte VW am Abend zur Ursache ist
bisher nichts bekannt
dieses Problem ist bekannt hohe
Strompreise belasten vor allem die
Unternehmen die zur Produktion viel
Energie brauchen die Chemie etwa helfen
würden Subventionen zum Beispiel ein
staatlich verbilligter Strompreis für
Großverbraucher den fordert die Branche
auch heute beim sogenannten
chemie-gipfel mit Bundeskanzler Scholz
und Vertretern der Länder die
Ampelkoalition ist da allerdings uneins
und der Kanzler sehr skeptisch nicht
zuletzt wegen der Kosten Thaddäus Parade
berichtet
der Chemiepark Marl im nördlichen
Ruhrgebiet einer der größten
chemie-standorte Deutschlands hier
produziert auch der Evonik-Konzern
erzählt zu den Top-Unternehmen der
Branche eine Milliarde Euro hatte
Warnung in Marl investiert in neue
Fertigungsanlagen und moderne
Gaskraftwerke doch angesichts extrem
hohe Energiekosten stellt sich die Frage
ist der Standort Deutschland noch zu
halten
die chemische Industrie in Deutschland
ist in einer schwierigen Situation die
ist krisenhaft das Problem dabei ist das
ist keine konjunkturelle Krise ist
sondern dass eine strukturelle Krise
droht die gesamte Führungsriege der
deutschen chemiereisen war mit
eindringlichen Zahlen im Gepäck zum
Kanzler nach Berlin gefahren denn im
Vorjahresvergleich sank die Produktion
um 10,4% auch der Branchenumsatz ging um
11,5% zurück nur ein staatlich
subventionierter Strompreis kann er
helfen so die Forderung doch dafür gab
es heute vom Kanzler keine Zusage
es ist aber nicht so dass das Hauptthema
nämlich die akuten hohen Energiepreise
einer Lösung zugeführt worden sind das
ist etwas enttäuschend auch wenn heute
kein Durchbruch beim Kanzler zustande
kam die Länder sind sich einig die 16
Länder sind in dieser Hinsicht sehr
eindeutig wir müssen die
energieintensive Wirtschaft in
Deutschland unterstützen die wir in
Zukunft noch dringend brauchen werden
die Gespräche im Kanzleramt sollen
fortgesetzt werden das Ziel spätestens
bis zum Jahresende einen Chemie packt
für Deutschland zu schnüren
das Pariser Klimaabkommen hat das Ziel
die Erderwärmung auf 1,5 Grad zu
beschränken das sei faktisch gescheitert
die Menschheit habe die Chance zu einer
Stabilisierung des Weltklimas verpasst
das erklärten Wetter und Klimaexperten
zum Auftakt des
extremwetterkongresses in Hamburg die
Erde stehe vor nicht mehr abwendbaren
massiven Veränderungen extremes Wetter
in Form von Hitzewellen oder Starkregen
wie in Griechenland oder libyen wird
demnach weiter zunehmen Andreas Stamm
ist bei mir aus unserer umweltredaktion
Andreas was bedeutet das müssen wir uns
damit abfinden dass die Erderwärmung
nicht mehr zu begrenzen ist nein es
bedeutet erstmal dass die Erderwärmung
weitergeht dass 1,5 Grad Ziel wird wohl
verfehlt da sind sich die Experten einig
denn nicht nur der Bundesregierung fällt
es einfach schwer in Zeiten der
Wirtschaftskrise Klimaschutzmaßnahmen
voranzutreiben aber es gibt auch eine
andere Botschaft eben von Deutschlands
führenden Klima und Wetterexperten nur
nicht den Kopf in den Sand stecken es
tun sich weltweit vielen Sachen
Klimaschutz trotz allem und wir müssen
eben jedes Zehntel Grad verhindern jedes
Zehntelgrad weniger das rechnet sich am
Ende und gerade die Klima
Extremereignisse in diesem Jahr die
Wetterereignisse haben ja gezeigt worauf
wir uns einstellen müssen und das ist
eine 1,2 Grad wärmere Welt wenn
überhaupt nichts passiert bewegen wir
uns auf drei Grad zu bis 2100 und das
hätte verheerende Konsequenzen alle die
dafür Angst haben wollen dass es
schneller geht manche kleben sich fest
das macht andere wütend aber es gibt
auch immer mehr die sich für einen
anderen Weg entscheiden und er ist
vielleicht etwas ja eleganter man klagt
vor Gericht man klagt Klimaschutzpolitik
ein bei den Regierungen die sich darauf
verpflichtet haben und das nimmt zu und
ist vielleicht ein sehr eleganter Weg
die Politik zum Handeln zu zwingen
vielen Dank für diese Einschätzung
Andreas Stamm
und auch unsere Kollegen von heute live
sprechen dazu gleich mit Experten unter
anderem mit dem Thema Forscher motivativ
um 19:30 Uhr auf unseren Social Media
Kanälen und auch sie versuchen das Klima
mit Hilfe von Richtern zu retten sechs
Kinder und Jugendliche aus Portugal sie
haben die deutsche und 31 andere
Regierungen verklagt vor dem
europäischen Gericht so für
Menschenrechte ihr Ziel per Gericht die
Regierungen zu strengeren Klimazielen zu
zwingen Christian
André Katharina Martin Mariana Claudia
und Sophia sind aus Portugal nach
Straßburg gekommen damit sich in Sachen
Klimaschutz etwas ändert die Länder die
sie verklagt haben tun zu wenig für den
Klimaschutz finden die Jugendlichen sie
sehen ihre Grundrechte verletzt
es ist sehr wichtig dass diese und
andere Generationen verstehen dass wir
das nicht nur für uns selbst machen
sondern für uns alle unsere Stimme ist
gemeinsam viel stärker
2017 Hitzewelle auf der iberischen
Halbinsel Temperaturen teilweise über 40
Grad dazu trockene Winde die
waldbrand-serie in dem Jahr besonders
verheerend vor allem diese Feuer seien
für die sechs Jugendlichen der Auslöser
gewesen aktiv zu werden sagen sie der
Klimawandel beeinträchtigt unseren
Alltag erzählt der 15-Jährige Andreas
ich möchte zum Beispiel in meinem Zimmer
sein und lernen oder schlafen aber es
ist so heiß dass das schwierig ist ich
möchte nach draußen gehen und nicht dort
bewegen können Fahrrad fahren oder
Basketball spielen aber es ist so heiß
dass ich es einfach nicht kann
aussagen wie diese sind wichtig denn die
Jugendlichen müssen die Richter in
Straßburg davon überzeugen dass sie
persönlich von den Folgen des
Klimawandels betroffen sieht die
Angeklagten Länder vertreten von über 80
Anwälten weisen die Anklage zurück sie
basiere auf bloßen Annahmen und Lehren
Hypothesen hieß es ein Urteil wird im
nächsten Jahr erwartet gewinnen die
Jugendlichen könnten den 32 Ländern hohe
Strafen drohen
manchen reicht ein Bild seines
legendären Badewannen Skechers und schon
haben Sie Tränen vor Lachen in den Augen
lorios Humor ist unerreicht im November
wäre sein hundertster Geburtstag aus
diesem Anlass feiert Ihnen das Museum
für komische Kunst in Frankfurt am Main
mit einer Ausstellung ach was heißt das
ganze ein großer Spaß zeigt Peter
Theißen
es sind Klassiker der deutschen
Fernsehgeschichte
ja das Ei ist hart
lorius Sketche sind ins kollektive
humorbewusstsein der deutschen
eingegangen
natürlich die Geschichte mit der Nudel
das Klavier das Klavier geniale Humor
den man vermisst heutzutage wiko von
Bülow geboren in Brandenburg wird als
18-Jähriger in den Krieg eingezogen und
zeichnet schon dort eindrucksvolle
Porträts der russischen Bevölkerung
zurück in Deutschland studiert der
Malerei und Grafik Zeitschriften werden
bald auf ihn aufmerksam
[Musik]
zu einer Legende wird er aber mit
Figuren wie Wurm und Wendelin im
Fernsehen
[Musik]
ich wünsche mir eine kleine Miezekatze
für mein Wochenendhaus und mit Sketchen
wie diesen
Lüdenscheid ich lasse jetzt das Wasser
ein wenn sie mich höflich darum bitten
bitte höflich das Besondere an lorius
Humor ist die Sorgfalt mit der eine
Sketche gedreht das stimmt das Timing er
geht da ja auch allgemein so als Pedant
aber man sieht dann nachher im Ergebnis
das was bleibenderes herausgekommen ist
als bei anderen Produktionen insgesamt
700 Exponate von lorius zeitlosen Humor
sind bis Februar in Frankfurt zu sehen
[Musik]
es ist immer wieder herrlich absolut
DFB-Pokal München hat in Münster nichts
anbrennen lassen genau klarer 14.07
gegen den Drittligisten die Bayern
können auch ohne Stürmerstar Hurricane
Siegen der wurde gestern geschont
schmerzlich dagegen der Armbruch von
Serge gnabry für ihn und für den FCB
mehrere Wochen würde ausfallen
Nationalspieler Serge gnabry war nur
vier Minuten auf dem Platz bis zum
Zusammenprall mit münsterstorbad
Johannes Schenk das sonst sehr wichtiger
Spieler eine Champions League getroffen
immer super torgefährlich und vom vom
Charakter von seiner Persönlichkeit
einfach sehr wichtig Harry bekommt eine
Pause aber das macht nichts Erik Maxim
Choupo-Moting springt ein und bringt die
Bayern früh in Führung bei Halbzeit
steht 3:0 mattis tel trifft Kurzschluss
zum 4:0 entstand so ein leichtes Spiel
kann Bayern am Samstag in der Bundesliga
nicht erwarten dann geht's nach Leipzig
Schalke 04 trennt sich von Cheftrainer
Thomas Reis der hatte vor 11 Monaten den
Job übernommen konnte aber weder den
Abstieg verhindern noch in der zweiten
Liga das Team auf Erfolgskurs bringen
S04 ist dort Tabellen 16 bis auf
weiteres über den Co-Trainer Matthias
Kreuzer den Posten
ja und eine Co-Trainerin die hat gestern
Abend die DFB Frauen wieder so richtig
in Schwung gebracht Britta Carlsson
Martina Voss Tecklenburg ist ja
weiterhin erkrankt nach der pleite-serie
ein befreiendes 140 in Bochum gegen
Island
Deutschlands Fußballfrauen haben
zumindest die Leichtigkeit ihres Tuns
wieder entdeckt nach all dem Fuß zuvor
Erleichterung und herzergreifende
Emotionen den Weg zum deutlichen 14.0
Sieg gegen Island ebnet das frühe Tor
von Clara Bühl die Olympia Hoffnungen
Leben weiter ständig Ovations auch für
Alexandra Popper ihre Auswechslung nicht
gleichbedeutend mit dem Karriereende der
Kapitänin ich glaube dass wir noch nicht
eine Klarheit jetzt in der Mannschaft
haben eine
um ja schon Tschüss zu sagen offen
dagegen ob Bundestrainerin Karlsson auch
im Oktober noch in vorderster Linie
stehen muss nächste Spiel 27 Oktober
gegen Wales bis dahin dürfte die
Trainerfrage geklärt sein
das Lotto die Gewinnzahlen lauten 2 9 19
22 40 41 und die Superzahl 8 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de
und im ZDF Text auf Seite
das Wetter bringt morgen wieder
Temperaturen bis 25 Grad und einiges an
Sonne Details hat gleich Christa orbin
Christian Sievers freut sich auf Sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn und
wir freuen uns wenn Sie morgen wieder
dabei sind einen schönen Abend noch auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute gab es wieder
schönstes Spätsommerwetter weite Teile
Europas waren heute wolkenlos das galt
aber nicht für kriechenland hier
herrscht wieder Unwettergefahr mit
kräftigen Gewittern und auch nicht für
die britischen Inseln die wurden nämlich
heute von einem Sturmtief erfasst uns
bringt dieses Sturmtief zum einen die
sehr warme Luft der september wird ja
viel zu warm zu Ende gehen zum anderen
bringt es uns Wolken hier die Wolken der
Kaltfront heute Nacht erreichen die den
Nordwesten in Südosten da bleibt es klar
örtlich bildet sich dich der Nebel wenn
der sich morgen aber aufgelöst hat
scheint im Südosten häufig die Sonne im
Nordwesten sind die dichteren Wolken
unterwegs aber es bleibt meist trocken
der Wind dreht auf Südwest und wird
lebhafter die Temperaturen sinken in der
Nacht im Süden auf 7 bis 12 Grad an der
Nordsee bleibt es bei 17 Grad durch
Wolken und Wind hier erreichen wir dann
morgen 20 Grad ansonsten gibt es wieder
Werte über 25 Grad sommerliche Werte im
Osten und im Südwesten des Landes ab
Freitag steigt dann die
Regenwahrscheinlichkeit mit etwas mehr
Wolken alles in allem geht der September
verabschiedet sich der September am
Wochenende aber mit ruhigen und vor
allem zu warmem Spätsommerwetter und
damit auf Wiedersehen